foreign
bro
there we go
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the Donia the three Muslims we're joined
here with the third Muslim today brother
Bobby because Angel couldn't make it but
he's gonna be here shortly inshallah
how's it going Bobby
yeah a long time no see guys so far so
good just finished my fasting and my
five prayers as well so I'm already in
full effect I know I'm enjoying a little
bit of electrolyte water to replenish in
the hot hot Thailand environment how
about you guys alhamdulillah man listen
it's crazy that we did a stream I think
2022 sometime
and it's been about a year and now
you're Muslim bro
so why don't we start right with that
going to your River story inshallah
sure so when we talked the last time I
was already researching at least for a
year
and it all started I believe in
2021 roughly when I opened up the Quran
to debunk it and I talked about this in
length on my YouTube channel I come from
an Orthodox Christian background for
people that don't know and I never
really looked into my own faith as very
little people do on the Balkans where I
am from people do not really research
and try to understand what the religion
entails they are much more likely to
Simply say we are
is this lagging can you still see me
yeah
it's a little laggy oh there we go we
got angel in this
one brother
converts
I don't know teach me
but it's um
they say congratulations in Arabic
I was saying Mubarak but it's not my
Brooke bro my Brooke
what do I say shukran
yeah
Habibi there's uh the amount of
overwhelming comments in the community
post saying that oh two of my favorite
YouTubers were always on hell in Bobby's
perspective and now not only are they
both Muslim but they're gonna be on the
stream together
so please carry on I'm late so forgive
me he's having his election of the water
bro
yeah yeah I have to replenish man it was
very hot today extremely dehydrated
you're in uh you're in Thailand right
now right I'm in Thailand now last time
we spoke about it you just came back
from Thailand right yeah yeah how you
like in Thailand brother man I'm loving
it brother I lived here before I'm very
very glad to be back finally
Europe can be nice as well but Thailand
is simply my home you know I left Europe
2014 and since then I've never really
been back home home being Germany
um yeah I just enjoyed you I like the
people and Thailand is the last place on
Earth where I thought I'm gonna revert
to Islam because Thailand from back in
the day I associated with freedom
partying and what not I don't have to go
into detail you know so yeah that was my
association with Thailand back in the
day and every time I was thinking about
getting back to Thailand I was thinking
about those things but Allah had a
better plan for me
yeah yeah we we had a brother that was
on and he actually reverted in Thailand
as well
it's insane around here in Bangkok where
I'm at
they have shahadas every single day new
rivers are flooding the Islamic Center
around here it's absolute craziness so
when I talked with them and I said I
want to do it they said they're all
right maybe in two or three weeks or so
because they don't have a free spot
that's absolutely amazing I don't know
Mass reversion here
that's beautiful yeah it is it is that's
amazing
yeah anyways back to my story I'm gonna
wrap that up because most people already
are familiar with my story so I want to
keep it short and concise
coming from an Orthodox Christian
background coming from the Balkans down
there people are not identified with the
Theology of the religion but they're
identified with the label so they are
Christians and they are proud Christians
and they defeated the Muslim Ottomans so
this is their narrative and every single
time somebody would even consider to
enter the fold of Islam he would be
labeled either a Turk or an Albanian
because they associate a specific
nationality with it
and I too back in the day I was ignorant
I was arrogant and I saw it the same way
I thought that Islam is only for the
Turks only for the albanians so I never
looked into it what I however looked
into was everything but so Buddhism
Hinduism new age psychedelics I hope I
can say that here
and I asked Shamanism and whatnot ended
up in the Amazon jungle Brewing my own
ayahaska with the shamans dancing in the
rainforest you know tried it all exactly
tried it all and in the end I was left
with basically nothing because I
understood that all of it was absolutely
empty and I was simply worshiping my ego
nothing else because once I gathered
those spiritual experiences I realized
actually I have something that other
people don't so maybe then I am better
than those people because most people
are simply reading books they only know
it in theory but now due to my
psychedelic experiences wow now I've
seen the Unseen right and I started
feeling yeah very proud of myself and
that's what I realized in the end it was
an ego worship and nothing else and I
felt empty so I had to return to God and
the only way to do that in my framework
was by returning to Christian Orthodoxy
because that's all I got and Islam is
the forbidden fruit right we don't touch
it it's enemy's territory
and so this is what I did I returned to
authors Christianity however this time
for the first time really analyzing
researching and trying to understand
what it entails and this means that I
was the first one in my family to do so
nobody in my family knows about the
trinity and the Orthodox people here on
YouTube
they were trying to expose me as a fake
Christian because I found out about the
trendy so late in my life
the reality is nobody on the Balkans or
maybe not nobody but the majority don't
know about the theology about the
Trinity Etc they don't see Jesus as God
either
nobody sees Jesus as God when I say
Jesus God
my mother asked me
so what is this about now you don't
believe in Jesus anymore I said I just
don't believe that Jesus is God
and she wondered who believes that Jesus
is God in the first place
exactly nobody does right so anyways I
was the first one to actually research
it and once I researched it I simply
couldn't stick with it anymore I
couldn't be at peace because it was
going against everything that I believed
which is basically there is one God
and this is why I decided then to debunk
Islam because if I
accomplish the banking Islam then
finally Christianity will make sense
again if I finally destroy the enemy and
I was even planning on making
anti-islamic videos
idiot
then
finally I will have firm Faith again
within Christianity and this is why I
opened up the Quran for the very first
time and once I started reading it
needless to say I made videos about this
Etc et cetera there was no going back
anymore once I opened that book for me
it was done because that book spoke
about nothing else but worshiping won
God alone and I couldn't believe that my
belief was found in that book I couldn't
believe that it was essentially like a
mirror just reflecting back to me what I
believed already
and this was the shock to me and I said
now everything falls into place so I can
finally let go of that belief system
that Jesus has got I can finally let go
of that belief system that there are
three persons in one God and I have to
put them mentally together and struggle
every single day to believe this finally
I can let go of this right but
at that point I wasn't ready to embrace
Islam I simply took the quran's word for
it and said maybe there's a
clarification for us Christians as well
right but what does that entail once you
accept that Jesus not God then the whole
crucifixion crumbles as well because
what's the purpose then so Jesus who
the Son of God a messenger but then he's
being sent by God to forgive all of our
sins and God cannot do that by himself
that didn't make any sense either and so
further down the line further down the
line the more I read the Quran
it simply destroyed my previous
misconceptions finally or new health
beliefs that I forced upon myself and
ultimately I had to embrace Islam there
was no choice anymore and I said that as
well on my channel hello dear hate us on
that note people said that I'm making
this for money
the truth is that if I wanted to do this
for money first and foremost I would
have dragged it out maybe another year
what Christian reacts to yay cool
there's more money in doing that than
accepting the truth and moreover yet
again coming from the Balkans I don't
want to go into too much detail because
it is my family so therefore I want to
respect this but I have not
one supportive family member quite the
opposite they all cut the contact with
me so I don't have any contact with my
father mother or sister anymore because
I accepted Islam okay so there's
something that is heartbreaking but it
is the truth
I accepted the truth because it is the
truth not because it is Pleasant not
because I get any benefits material
benefits out of it just because it is
the truth and that is the whole reason
behind it so therefore anybody that was
thinking this is some sort of publicity
stunt or whatnot you have to understand
that reverting from my position
is not a walk in the park I heard about
many Americans having liberal parents
and they don't really care oh okay Islam
interesting let me look into it or not
who cares but for me they called me
the traitor of the family of the nation
and whatnot for this you know so I have
everything to lose basically in this
world but at the same time everything to
gain in the Hereafter so therefore
Allahu Akbar I'm happy
that was beautifully said man let me
make it easy for you and uh I wanna know
the brother's thoughts on that
man I mean honestly it's it's it's
heartbreaking for me to hear
um but uh Bobby have you I just want to
give you a hug man I just want to
embrace you it's not a lot may Allah
bless you happy one life it's very
beautiful to speak to you again and uh
your story is one that is very inspiring
alhamdulillah you know for myself even
as a board Muslims upon Allah it really
it just reminds me how you know
fortunate some of us were to be born
with Islam subhanallah and how bless the
you know the rivers are that Allah had
guided them from such a place to the
truth to Islam and may Allah bless you
and reward you and I want to take this
time inshallah to say a few um good
words here because
not only did you you know just accept
Islam and you know you probably know
that accepting Islam forgives all sins
Allah forgives the person who just comes
to accept the truth for the first time
but right before Ramadan as well you
know right before Ramadan and now you
have the opportunity to experience the
most beautiful month of the year in
which contains a day that is worth more
than a thousand months in it subhanallah
you know
I think that is such a blessing as well
there is so much emphasis put on the
month of Ramadan how rewarding it is
for Muslims to observe the fasting so um
it's very beautiful to see that Allah is
bless you with Islam right before that
month as well so may Allah bless you so
how has your Ramadan been and how has it
been like integrating to the Muslim
Community
yeah first and foremost thank you very
much for your kind words moreover I see
it as an absolute blessing and almost a
miracle that all happened before Ramadan
if I would have liked to plan it I
couldn't have planned it this way you
know ultimately I had a live stream with
chef with Mom and I believe there's
already eight or nine months ago
and he answered pretty much all of my
questions so therefore I said to him
you know what if I ever chose to convert
to revert then I will do it with you and
I gave my word right then right there so
now the last two to three months have
been absolutely terrible physically here
I said this offline I got diagnosed with
an autoimmune disorder
I was suffering every day unbelievable
fevers couldn't properly eat and what
not couldn't work out anymore I would go
to Jitsu one session next day I couldn't
get out of bed anymore so I had to stop
training lifting weights lost 15 kilos
and whatnot
during that time I'm having this
physical battle but this internal
struggle as well and so I'm thinking to
myself man I have to submit this too
much I have to submit I have to say the
shahada that's it however because I
promised sharehold man we're going to do
it together I'm writing him hey man I
need to do the shahada what's up with
you and he tells me he's going to be
here in God knows how many weeks
it is what it is I already accepted my
heart now I can only pray to God to
preserve me till then and I'm gonna wait
and I'm gonna keep my promise and then
we're gonna do it here
so it was due to a certain medication
they prescribed me here really two days
before I took my shahada then I was
actually able to get out of bed and do
the Sharda physically otherwise I
couldn't even get the strength to get
out you know so it all lined up like
that and before Ramadan finally I
reverted you know so this was for me the
biggest blessing that Allah chose it so
beautifully and that I get to experience
Ramadan the Blessed month you know for
me there's absolutely mind-blowing still
to this very day so how is it so far
due to this autoimmune condition and
even prior to that I did all kinds of
crazy fasts so I did 24-hour fast with
no issues whatsoever for a year straight
I think I would have one meal a day
every 24 hours
there was a fantastic time period as
well where I did one meal per day only
with bananas that was absolutely amazing
please everybody try it it's so good you
just eat 10 bananas and then you go to
bed at least you're trying to phenomenal
yeah so
fasting itself was never too problematic
for me and even now as I said already
passed yet again 24 hours sometimes 30
hours and whatnot but the dry fasting
here in Thailand is something on another
level which I appreciate however because
a new challenge I have never done a dry
fast this long and especially not at 40
degrees celsius I don't know what that
is in Fahrenheit
but it's hot it's really hot and I have
a son myself so I'm playing with him in
the sun all day long sweating sweating
sweating sweating sweating so this is
pretty pretty tough nevertheless I
experience a mental Clarity and a piece
in myself that I cannot even describe
truly I don't know how true it is
because I'm still learning some people
told me during Ramadan shaytan is locked
up and this is how it feels so I'm
encountering a lot of issues privately
as I described but it doesn't affect me
you know I'm very very happy so it's all
good
I could be God forbid but in the middle
of an earthquake or whatnot I think I
would be still smiling I'm very very
happy and I'm enjoying it a lot so
the Muslim Community here in Thailand is
nothing short of breathtaking man when
Sheikh Woodman came here he was amazed
himself because before that he used to
come here for business trips he told me
and he only saw the secular aspect and
the to be quite Frank degenerate aspect
of Thailand especially Bangkok there's a
lot of that as well and so now when he
saw the Muslim Community here he was
amazed man we met a guy who was a rock
star matter of fact the most famous rock
star in Thailand if you check his videos
160 million clicks huge huge and this
man reverted to Islam
his contract
the time Mafia was after him man they
want to kill the guy absolutely insane
he left everything behind million dollar
contracts to revert to Islam you know he
accepted Islam and now he has his own
little YouTube channel promoting Islam
and he has a restaurant chain if anybody
is in Thailand check it out it's called
beef Masters it's all Halal very amazing
very good beef invited us there so
everybody has been absolutely welcoming
I have such a good Community around me
here the mosques are absolutely
breathtaking as well I've never seen
such beautiful architecture the most
here in Bangkok where I took my shahada
as well is an open mosque and around it
you just have palm trees everywhere on
Friday the mosque is packed like this
and outside the parking lots man you
cannot walk through because everybody's
praying outside the premises hundreds
and hundreds of people so the community
here is nothing that I would ever
expected to find here in Thailand that's
absolutely amazing I'm blessed
um which area in Thailand is this yellow
like Southern Thailand is it Phuket is
it Chiang Mai no brother I'm in Bangkok
out of all places I'm in Bangkok
and nobody would believe that you know
because I'm aware and everybody else is
aware in Bangkok you have a lot of
partying red lights and whatnot but you
have a huge Muslim Community that most
people do not know about and you know
how it is once your OPI is to something
you see it everywhere right so back in
the day for example I talk about it
always and I sound like a broken record
but when I went vegan
all of a sudden you see vegan
restaurants everywhere oh wow here you
can eat vegan food yes well I didn't
know it before and now coming back to
Thailand maybe it is due to the increase
of Islam as well but I see hijabis
everywhere Muslims everywhere in the
area of Bangkok where I'm living we have
the biggest Islamic Center I believe at
least in Thailand if not in Southeast
Asia it's humongous and it's always
packed you know so it's an amazing
amazing Community I would like to check
out the south soon yet again but for now
I'm very happy here yeah
yeah I recommend if you ever get the
chance when you go to Chiang Mai
get a get like a car or a bike because I
think you said you have a son so I'm
going to assume that you have a wife as
well yeah of course a wife and she is
thank God pregnant again so we're
waiting
that's beautiful it's beautiful I do
have some questions on that which I'll
leave after this but sure if you ever
get to Chiang Mai rent a car and drive
up to May Hong song
listen I think this is the most
the most spiritual place that I've ever
been in Thailand it's like proper
problem Muslims like
you you'll feel it yourself when you go
there it's really beautiful is this
where Charizard came from
that's what Charizard was so if you know
you know if you're a day one t3m fam
member then you're gonna know where
that's from but brother Bobby I had a
very important question for you that a
lot of people when they have this
proclivity to accept Islam from the
heart their ego or their nuffs or like
basically like mentally on some type of
conscious level they have these doubts
or barriers and they either delay it or
they tell themselves they're not ready
yet have you had any doubts or things
that blocked you and how did you
overcome them
of course I adults so the first doubt
that I had was
that I won't be able to fully accept
Islam and commit to it because I knew
myself and I know my past so during my
past I went through all kinds of
different ideologies theologies diets
and whatnot so my biggest fear was truly
that I won't be able to commit to it
because I will find something within it
that will then put me off it again and
there was a legitimate fear in myself
because I know myself and I know what
I've been through that was the biggest
one and therefore after opening up the
Quran
as I said already there I witness the
truth within that book however I was
trying to find the faults and the
mistakes within Islam the organized
religion and this is why at first I was
kind of sticking to a quranist approach
almost as well and I was saying still to
myself maybe the hadiths are
wrong or man-made you know there was
always something so that was my
irrational doubt basically it wasn't so
rational it was about trying to find
further thoughts within the concept
before accepting it that was the biggest
one
however ultimately man
if you have the message of one God
what is there not to accept
if you look at all the religions there
is not one religion that proclaims
monotheism as Islam does there is not
one
you only have three monotheistic
religions the big ones one of them says
goddess Triune the other one says we
want argument against God in a wrestling
match as well
and there's only one left that says God
is the Supreme the ultimate power
nobody is like him
right so there is really no other option
ultimately am I lagging as well
no you lag but but you keep speaking so
it's it's perfect
let me take another sip of the
electrolyte man um
yeah so it wasn't so much about
rationalizing quite the opposite man
because I knew it in my heart and it
went even so far that a dream roughly
two months ago
in my struggling in my fever and whatnot
I had this dream I found myself
levitating and I'm flying over an
Islamic City I don't know where it is
and I see all those mosques all those
minarets
and all of a sudden I hear they are done
but the Adan is not coming from the
mosques it's coming from my heart
and I just hear it in my heart and it
says
[Music]
and it starts breaking out and it goes
up through my throat and wants to come
out of my mouth
and I myself forced myself to keep it
shut I didn't want to Proclaim it just
yet
and I want to keep it shut but it
bursted out of my heart and I said the
shahada and it was just spreading all
across the city over the rooftops you
could hear it Echo
and it was just flying like this you
know Proclaim their Shabba and I woke up
right away after this I was like wow you
know I couldn't hold it down anymore so
this dream for me was already like my
shoulder because my heart declared it
and it wanted to exit my lips but I was
the only one
essentially stopping it
and when I said that to one Muslim
friend of mine he said bro you're
already Muslim man what are you doing
now what are you doing here
and yeah so I was fighting something
very irrational in the end it was not
rational anymore it was about me not
being able to commit it was maybe there
is something hidden somewhere that I
will find out and whatnot it was very
irrational so therefore to analyze I can
only say this must have been shaytan
then in the end truly trying to delay it
that's the only thing I can come up with
yeah so when when was this dream by the
way
I believe it was two months ago or so I
can't pinpoint it two months ago and
when were you diagnosed with the
autoimmune disorder
diagnosed properly just a month ago but
my sickness is already ongoing for at
least half a year and the worst part of
it were the last three months
that's crazy
yeah
you still do the the carnival like meat
and fruits
right now because of the fasting I'm not
doing only meat and fruits I'm doing
some starches as well because I want to
replenish my glycogen and keep it full
for longer because when you're not
eating you need something in the
storages stop eating some white rice as
well but other than I'm eating healthier
always do you feel do you feel like um
when you started suffering with the
sickness that you had changed the way
that you ate or were you eating roughly
the same
no I was eating roughly the same man
I
I got I don't know if I can say it here
yet again I don't want us to get
demonetized so I got the flu right the
famous food that was around in Germany
and I thought I'm gonna die
I thought I'm gonna die really and I was
the guy that was so vocal speaking
against her that's the common flu is not
going to do anything to you but it hit
me so hard that I thought I'm gonna die
after that I couldn't properly recover
so for months and months and end I
couldn't properly breathe I had really
issues exercising etc etc I was very
tough and then when I got to Thailand it
hit me again
and again so I got it three times in a
row and after that third time my body
couldn't recover anymore so no matter
what I tried it just didn't work and it
seemed as if it is attacking itself and
that's why ultimately the diagnosed me
with the autoimmune disorder where they
confirmed that my body truly is
attacking itself it tried to fight off
the flu and then once the flu was gone
it kept on attacking itself
that's why I don't know yeah that's okay
that's all the test
[Music]
um
I mean I mean let's let's answer this
question so
what's our ethnicity and we won't also
answer uh get Bobby the answer too so
Bobby what's your ethnicity
that's a very interesting question as
always I cannot just explain it in one
word or one sentence I could just say
Macedonian and there will be it but it's
not the case so one of the reasons why
I've been already called the Public
Enemy Number One in my country I've was
on the national news and even a little
bit international news in Europe and
Greece and Bulgaria and I was declared
the Public Enemy Within Macedonia is the
reason because I actually did the
research just as I did with Islam and
want to find out what Macedonia is
Macedonia is a small country which has
roughly 2 million inhabitants 500 000 of
which are Muslim albanians and 1.5 are
Slavs they used to be part of the
greater Yugoslavia and Yugoslavia means
essentially Southern Slavs so I was
wondering if there are countries like
Germany or France and Europe that are so
big how can it be that on the Balkan we
have those small little bits and pieces
in every body allegedly is so different
so dug deep I researched I researched
and I found out ultimately that we're
ethnically bulgarians I found that out
through the ottoman records the Muslim
ottoman records they tracked the
population in Macedonia and everybody
back then was identified as a Bulgarian
until the Communist propaganda started
spreading and they denied their
Birthright of being bulgarians what
happened then is the genocide
persecution and people got essentially
brainwashed into believing now we are
macedonians
and this is something that I don't
identify with so nationally I'm coming
from Macedonia I grew up in Germany but
ethnically I can only identify with
Bulgarian
um which is why my family hates me as
well so now I'm a Bulgarian Muslim not a
Macedonian Christian
mine is a little bit simpler I'm just
Bengali 100 what about you two nice
Palestinian
bro you made me want to like pull out my
uh 23andMe bro on my ancestry.com or
something like this let's do it bro
no I mean look my my parents are Puerto
Rican but
um as far as Puerto Rican goes like when
I looked into what's the uh
like where they come from you know like
what are the races there and it's
usually middle eastern African European
and Native American so I'm just I'm just
bro that's all I am
foreign
of all kinds of different ethnicities
have you ever done a DNA test
I did but you know you saying how like
you went into like the online records
and you saw this stuff it kind of makes
you want to like dig deeper and like
really see like what else I can find
with this man
you can take your raw data so you can
download it as a PDF I believe and then
you can re-upload it on a page called
jet match I'm not sponsored or anything
jetmatch.com and it's an open source
page it doesn't cost you anything and
there you will see a detailed breakdown
of every ethnicity so for example if you
have something African it can tell you
in detail which country of Africa you
would be which tribe of Africa you would
come from et cetera et cetera so it goes
into tremendous detail I would recommend
it jetmich.com
gedmatch.com check it out okay okay it's
free of charge it doesn't cost anything
make sure to put your uh your your
referral link I got it
I'm just I'm just playing bro I'm just
playing so brother you had said that you
you met up with and yeah from what I saw
on on YouTube you actually had several
several videos on that and then
uh then you guys spoke about Hadith as
well but how was this experience like
what did you guys talk about and all
this stuff I'm very very curious
is a real bro he's a good guy man you
can just chill with him you can have
jokes with him he's a normal guy you
know so for some people they've seen it
online and they get maybe intimidated by
the beard and the throat and whatnot you
know and the title Shake he's just a
normal guy so we had a lot of fun he did
this for me so ultimately he had plans
to stay in Indonesia and in Malaysia I
believe but he booked a flight and came
over for one night
so I found a hotel for him and he stayed
two or three minutes away from me matter
of fact right now recording this I can
see the hotel is just next to my place
here
and he came over he invited some Thai
Muslims over as well they never saw him
before either and apparently they were
watching my YouTube channel as well so
it was nice we got a little get-together
and we went straight ahead to a
restaurant he wanted to do a podcast
right away the guy is a professional man
he started shooting shorts hey Bobby
here I have a present for you he gave me
like an Indonesian Muslim rope yeah take
this and there right away I recorded a
short for YouTube and I said man I just
want to get to know each other here you
know we can have some food first I'm not
in that mindset right now because
outside from what I'm doing on YouTube
in front of my laptop I don't feel like
a YouTuber when I'm outside at all
whatsoever you know so it's very very
strange when somebody recognized me here
in Thailand oftentimes people recognize
me now in the mosque and ah Bobby's
perspective for me is so weird I don't
like it to be honest you know but
anyways so he on the other hand was
totally professional and during the ride
to the restaurant he was telling me
about what we have to talk about etc etc
and I said man let's just talk about
whatever we talked about plenty of
topics that we cannot unfortunately
discuss online as well he's a very
transparent guy when it comes down to
certain truths that are suppressed
certain political issues that are
suppressed as well very very
yeah straight accurate man then we had
some food here he was very happy to have
some Halal Burgers because apparently in
America you cannot find Halal Burgers he
was a big fan of those here in Thailand
now overall we talked about
pretty much everything we talked about
Thailand itself how it comes that there
are so many Muslim and how come that
there are so many ladyboys at the same
time just
just stuff like that so the experience
itself was actually quite amazing
because no matter where we went to the
mosque here everybody recognized him as
well they all got Star Struck all the
shake the shake everybody want to take
pictures
but for me personally as I said for me
it was just a brother especially after
accepting Islam he's just a brother you
know we're a human and nobody is God so
yeah we just had a fantastic time he
enjoyed the
Steakhouse guys here as well very much
the community and he would like to come
back he told me after that we recorded
podcast as well guys in person
as I said he's a professional he woke me
up at what was it 8 AM or something I
said come on let's record this podcast
now before we do the shahada okay let's
do it man why not so it was my last
podcast as a Christian if you will as
somebody that has reverted yet
yeah it was amazing man really good time
very intense and after 24 hours
basically he was gone he landed 4 pm and
he had to leave at roughly 6 PM the next
day
you guys spoke about the Hadith
yeah so you said that you were um you
almost like you didn't want to I don't
know you didn't want to find like fault
within the Hadith so you didn't want to
think like oh you come across something
you're like oh well here's this and I
won't be able to like really you know
practice as much as I want to practice
because then you got this Elite and it's
making me feel this way and other stuff
like how was all that within and the
conversation that you had and like what
were the doubts leading into it what
were the answers that he gave you
and yeah yeah
he's a Hadith scholar right so therefore
he assured me and the group as well
because he was talking to a bunch of
friends of mine as well that the Hadith
or the Hadith science is more meticulous
than any other type of science even
biology is that so any other research
history it's much meticulous and then he
gave us the example of how it truly
works so how the people have to be
analyzed assessed what kind of character
they have who said what etc etc so he
gave us essentially the lines and the
chains of narration and how they really
function and that was the first time for
me to see it live basically a
presentation of how that works still
though and I know people are going to
hate me for that I am extremely stubborn
but the good news is this is why I'm
here
if I weren't so stubborn I would never
keep on researching keep on digging and
trying to find the truth when it comes
down to Hadith I said it to him as well
in person I believe what you're saying
of course but I have to take your word
for it
the whole point is very simple the Quran
I read myself from cover to cover so no
I'm not an Islamic scholar I cannot
assess it properly but I read the whole
book by myself and it convinced me my
heart
when it comes down to the Hadith I
simply haven't read all of them and I
don't even know if it's possible to read
all of them right but I haven't read
sufficient enough to make up my mind so
if I have learned anything from my past
is that I wasn't only ignorant but I was
arrogant as well I thought that I know
and this is why nowadays I'm very
cautious by making certain claims am I
still skeptical yes of course I guess I
will be my whole life about everything
otherwise I just give up my own
intellect and just accept everything the
way that is of course I have to research
I have to dig and even the Quran asks us
as well right to think to do our own
research to find out and this is why so
for me personally I will just have to
read even more Hadith to affirm it by
myself through experience because that's
just how I function
but at the moment I'm not here to tell
anybody oh I know exactly what their
ideas are about how could I sharehold
man studied Hadith Sciences so he knows
way more than I will ever know probably
right but to affirm a certain subject by
myself I have to do more digging by
myself that's it
Grant you the knowledge that you're
looking for
how is it with you since you reverted
have you read
many hadiths do you know I don't know do
you know in my heart or whatnot how does
it look like for you what part I can't
does it play in your life
so bro I I was gonna say man I really
think this is something that Rivers have
you know we start first and we accept
the the Quran but then it's like we have
this process where it's like now we have
to accept the Hadith and the brothers
here and The Originals here know that
like in the beginning I completely
rejected the hadiths and I think a big
part of like why people reject Hadith is
uh again it's it's wanting to know
wanting to be sure but then also it
could be emotional you know it could
just be something that they don't agree
with maybe like emotionally they're just
not about what's being said in the
Hadith you know personally like at the
time I was doing uh fighting and I
wanted to do professional fighting and
there's a Hadith which says uh they're
striking the faces
so it's like clearly you know that's
going against what I'm trying to do so
like a part of me wanted to reject that
Hadith just based on the emotion that I
had gotcha um but in that man
I can't say that I really memorized a
whole bunch of them there are some that
I know about alhamdulillah but it's more
so like
you just take your time with it and
Allah starts to reveal everything to you
as you go
you know it's just like you reading the
Quran and and you looking for these
answers like
you were trying to dispute it you were
trying to like really see like debunk
Islam that was just really it is this
really true or anything like that but
it's like Allah revealed to you over
time like yeah not only is this the
truth
but it's it's everything you've been
looking for
absolutely
yeah I totally understand this man see
at the moment I have to admit I'm
enjoying Islam and the tradition of it
so for example when I learned praying I
know people always say it it's found in
the Hadith so praying is found in Hadith
how would you pray
the effect of the matter is a friend
taught me how to pray right so I'm
enjoying it in real life I go to the
mosque every Friday even before I revert
it I was going to the mosque already for
a month straight because I wanted to get
a flavor of it I want to understand it
if this is for me which sounds
ridiculous but anyways my point is that
right now Ramadan
I'm reading the Quran again because it's
the month of the Quran so right now I'm
not digging into Hadith either
as for right now
I'm having more to experience than I
ever asked for you know it's absolutely
beautiful I pray five times per day I go
to the mosque every Friday sometimes in
the week as well I have so many brothers
around here that I can meet now you know
we go out to eat if done and whatnot so
yeah they're a little bit on the back
burner at the moment
and I will further look into it once the
time comes you know but I'm taking it
step by step because I learned that as
well from past experiences I would jump
into a thing head first and then burn
out very fast as well and so now I'm a
bit older than you guys I believe I'm 35
years old
so now I'm taking it it's much much
slower you know
I have the rest of my life you know to
pray too fast it's all good I don't have
to rush it this time yeah so brother I
think something that I would really like
highly suggest is uh start to look into
the life of the Prophet Muhammad
yeah because
the more you start to learn about a
profit
which do you know what that means by the
way
foreign
and once you start to realize like more
and more like his character who he was
and like how he did everything
you start to now look into the Hadith
and you look at it with a different
perspective whereas before you may have
looked at it uh maybe too logical maybe
you may have looked at it maybe too
emotional but now when you look at it
and you understand like who the prophet
is to a certain extent it's it's
different it hits you different we're
like wow these words this is not just
any men it's not just any man it's the
prophet of Allah
and then on top of this you have like
he mentioned there's a meticulous way
that you actually have to grade the uh
the Hadith you have to like see which
one is actually proper which one is not
so the ones that I saw here these are
these are the truth like there's a
hundred percent like no Muslims were
disagree
well actually I'll take them back there
are some awesome they'll probably
disagree but it's probably emotional at
that point you know so you have it it's
like it's truth it's there and um when
you see something like this and then you
understand who it's coming from it has A
New Perspective in your mind that's
where you can you can start to make more
connections and uh inshallah
it may open the doors for you and you
start understanding more and more yeah
like in the in the in the Sharia bro in
Islam like one authentic Hadith like
Asahi Hadith has the same legislative
Authority as an eye on the Quran we
understand that you know when it comes
to the Quran of course it's the word of
Allah right and the Hadith are
definitely narrations from mankind but
just like you said when you really look
into the meticulous rigidity of Hadith
Sciences it's not a joke bro
can you recommend any specific material
on the Sera of the prophet
right now
the sealed nectar
I want to recommend something a little
bit different I know people always
recommend the books and I think the
books are amazing and you will get a lot
more out of the books than anything else
if you're a reader you read it inshallah
I was never always you know practicing
right I wasn't always practicing so I
came to really start practicing seven
when I was maybe like 16 ish and
I fell in love with this stuff just from
one like video lecture
but when I listened to the theater of
the process
and I was listening to the the whole
series all the lectures
um but I by the time I got to the end I
was completely crying
and I tell you like to this day I
remember I was laying down in my mom's
bed and you know sun shining from the
window and I was listening to the pseudo
and it spoke about the end of the life
of the process and I completely started
bawling as completely changed my life so
if you're a person who likes listening
right
I would say even try some of the
lectures I'll try and find the one I was
listening to or or others inshallah and
I can send it over to you but
I'm telling you I mean me personally it
has completely changed my life and I
think anyone you know who especially a
man you know looking at like the legend
of the process that I'm seeing he was a
father he was a warrior he was a fighter
he had he was a man on a mission to
implement Islam I think that's
something's got that's going to touch
everyone's heart inshallah on the topic
of Hadith actually
I think it might
it might help to put it like this
imagine we lived at the time of the
Prophet saws
imagine we lived with him and he was the
one who was receiving the Quran and
teaching it to the people
and you would read an Ayah and you're
not exactly sure what it means so you go
and you ask him right and he gives you
that answer
then you as a companion you pass down
that knowledge to your children into the
people you know around you and they pass
it down and they pass it down and
eventually it gets to a scholar of
Hadith who looks at each individual in
that chain going back to the process you
as at the beginning of the chain you
know the prophet said it and you being
there you know you asked him the
question and he said it in regards to
this so now in hindsight we get to
actually see the full chain or we get to
analyze every individual knowing that it
actually goes back to the prophet peace
be upon himself and I think that's when
it becomes more clear you know for
people who struggle with it and I
struggled with it slightly in the
beginning as well because it becomes a
question of well this is not the word of
God this is the word of a manner the
word of word of men and you know a man
wrote it down x amount of years after
the prophet peace be upon them but
that's I don't think the right way to
frame it because that's that's kind of
reductive you reduce it to just oh a man
put it in a book
but where did this actually come from
because when you ask yourself the
question did the prophet really say
these words peace be upon him then it
becomes a little more real
see there was there was a scholar The
mauritanian Scholar on One path Network
shout out to them I think a few days ago
and anytime he was asked like about
Hadith right like tell me about this
Hadith you would basically say Okay
um basically I got this from my father
who got it from his father and then he
would literally trace it back to the
prophet saws like that's the level that
he that he understood the chain of
narration and I think that's just
profound bro subhanallah so it's
definitely different than just hearsay
or this is what we believe everything is
linked and traced
yeah and brother think about this how
many people nowadays who will go on
social media and they'll find like some
random quote that someone puts up and
they're like oh wow look at this like
it's so amazing this hits you so
different you know it's like bro okay
these quotes are from humans
and you know some of them might actually
be great but then when you look at the
hadiths like there's so much wisdom
there's so much experience and knowledge
inside of these hadiths where it's like
one of the hadiths the prophet Muhammad
is saying that the people who you hang
around like the the company he's saying
uh it's better to be alone than to be in
bad company but it's better to be in
good company than to be alone
and then he goes on to say I don't know
if it's the same exact Hadith or it's a
different one but he says that the
people who you hang around is going to
be a direct influence on you well like
let's say you hang around someone who's
like a blacksmith you don't even touch
the equipment but just because you're
around him you're gonna smell like the
equipment you're gonna smell like the
musk like the iron
it's like you hang around someone who's
selling perfume even if you don't touch
the perfume you're gonna leave and
you're gonna smell like the perfume so
this is tell me that's not wisdom
tell me that's not wisdom
yes absolutely I mean nowadays when
you're talking about quotes those quotes
don't have a chain of narration
whatsoever so it's kind of funny when
they say Buddha set are you sure about
that exactly exactly right now I'm not
denying that there is any wisdom in
Hadith I mean God forbid of course the
fear that I had with Hadith prior was
that I thought that it could be used as
a tool to obstruct certain things we
find within the Quran and then I heard
about certain forgeries with Hadith and
there was a period of the so-called
Hadith Wars and that made me uncertain
so I'm not
at all afraid that there is something
valuable or something that might be
going against my own personal biases as
you mentioned with the boxing and that
goes against what you actually wanted to
do you cannot hit the face Etc et cetera
it was more about is it truly preserved
because with the Quran I had the promise
given by God that it will be preserved
that was my initial fear when it comes
down to Hadith you know
yeah you know let me um sorry I want to
add another perspective to it because if
you can enter this with the Quran then
that kind of sets it straight so Allah
he would not reveal Islam as the final
Deen the final religion if it was to be
corrupted right he also said in the
Quran all throughout that the prophet
peace be upon Him is a person who not
only is an example for us which already
means we have to like look at him and
see how he lived and there's no way to
do that without Hadith but at the same
time he said something very specific he
said they they will never truly believe
until they make you the prophet peace be
upon him a judge between them and their
disputes
and they submit themselves in full
submission you know and living in this
day and age there's no way to really
know what the prophet sallam said or did
or or how he lived or how he acted or
you know what the companions asked and
how he would respond except through
Hadith so now it's less of a matter of
did the men do a good job and more of a
matter of did Allah fulfill his promise
of preserving Islam as the final
religion
there's a pretty powerful perspective
that I haven't taken before that makes
sense yeah just just something to
reflect on inshaallah but let's move
away from the topic of Hadith and
because we're probably going to be
wrapping up and let's jump back into
Bobby Bobby's perspective to be
completely clear so subhanallah it's
been Ramadan for a few days
alhamdulillah you've been Muslim for a
few days
um but you were really looking into
Islam for a very very long time I know
you mentioned that you're kind of you
know maybe meticulous when it comes to
this and you're very kind of
strong-headed in finding out the truth
but
what was the final straw for you what
made you say okay I am going to become a
Muslim now or when did it really settle
in your heart
that's it there is no God but God man
that's what it was all alone you know
once I opened up the book as I said from
the get-go that was the message what
else is there
was not a final straw in that sense it
was just wrestling with my ego
and submitting myself
because the truth was present it was
already there
it was only up to me to accept it
and as I said during the struggle with
the sickness and the dream and whatnot
I just saw what I was doing and I was
resisting
and that brought me back to and people
can think about this what they want to
my past experiences with certain
so-called plant medicines
even there I had an experience where I
saw that we just have two options in our
life
we can either submit our will
or we can Rebel
there is really no other mode of
operation essentially in this life
you're either in total submission or you
are in Rebellion
which brings us back to the all the
story of Satan ibris rebelling against
God
and this is like a reflection like a
Rippling down that we see in humanity
we can either be like in police and
repel or we can submit like the angels
and this is this internal fight that
we're going through every single day
until we submit
and what I realized then is that what
other option do I have other than to
submit do I want to be of the people
that Rebel do I want to be amongst the
who the Richard Dawkins that tells me
that he doesn't want to believe in the
sky daddy is that a life that you want
to live is it a life that is worth
living or is it somebody that knows the
truth that there is only one God but he
keeps on adding certain Concepts on top
and tries to convince himself that Jesus
must be God and that the Trinity is true
so what kind of existence would that be
for me it would be an existence of
suffering because I'm consistently
rebelling and not submitting
so that was my past reflection and when
I realized that there was nothing else
left but to submit my will
because even if you look into Buddhism
they talk about that Buddha might or
might have not said we don't have a
Hadith that life is suffering life is
suffering
why is that the quintessence of the
ideology what did he truly understand
it is an aspect of life that life is
suffering
but there is a way out of suffering I
say as well because once you submit your
will to God there is no real suffering
anymore things just happen and you deal
with them
as a test
there is no suffering left you
understand so that was basically it I
just realized that for me I had to
conclude it with myself
once it was in my heart I simply had to
Proclaim it and that's it oh yeah that's
that's absolutely beautiful
alhamdulillah and I think everyone has a
bit of that because it's it's never like
a switch you know flick a switch and all
of a sudden you know okay I'm changed
I'm Different overnight but it's usually
a journey and that's a part of the
reason Allah he sent down the Quran over
time in over 23 years he said that we
sent it down in periods or in a long
period of time so that we can you know
continue to strengthen the hearts of the
Believers because this stuff is a
journey and the Apostle he said that
there's benefit in the reminder so being
even just reminded you know Allah
proclaims to be the one God where he
says
there's no God except him or there's no
God except Allah many times in the Quran
because just hearing it again and again
and again is something that
re-solidifies it within you and within
everyone as human beings but you said
something very very beautiful at the end
and it I think it's very befitting
because the process he actually said
this and he said amazing is the state of
a Believer you know it begins by saying
that the save a Believer is beautiful
because anything that happens to him is
here it's good he says if he's Afflicted
with some some trust and tests and
tribulations and trouble then he's
patient and that's better for him you
know meaning Allah will reward him and
if he's given something that is good
that he sees as good and that's ease
then he will be grateful and that is
better for him subhanallah and I think
you summarize yourself very beautifully
as well life is just a series of events
and when it's difficult you take it you
know and once when it's when it's ease
and Blissful you take it as well
alhamdulillah
um
this being said yes
no I was just gonna say like I I don't
know if um
if you notice that Bobby but I noticed
that when I became Muslim is that
Muslims like we just deal with things so
much better than everyone else and it's
not to say that we're better it's just
to say this like we understand
we understand like you said it's just a
test
we had a brother on here and he's he was
speaking about that like his wife
had a uh a miscarriage and he will yeah
you could tell he felt emotion from it
but this man still he literally said
like alhamdulillah like and you're still
grateful for everything
of course
yeah because how else would you have
trust if you don't have God you said it
doesn't mean that we are better than
anyone else
no God is better God is greater right so
this is why you're dealing better
because God is in your life how else
would you deal with things if you don't
have any God in your life then you see
all of those outward occurrences and
they become personal
right and they're nagging at you and
you're trying to find the fault in
things but once you submit to the will
of God there is no fault in things it
just is and there is a greater wisdom to
it you have to accept it it's
essentially like my child here as a
father
if he wants to eat chocolates and let
him eat chocolate
all day long it's going to get fat it's
gonna get diabetic it's going to get
sick it's gonna ruin his life
why would I let that happen I don't so I
take the children away so now my kid is
crying and now he's rebelling
and I'm the worst person in his life
right I'm the enemy now I'm the Satan
for him how can I destroy his date
but the reality is I know better than
him right and that's on a human level I
simply know better than my son
so for him it's a tragedy for him it's
the worst possible scenario this little
chocolate that's not in his mouth but in
my hand
that's the same with God how would I
know
what is good for me I cannot know that
ultimately what I interpret as suffering
how would I know that it's truly bad I
don't know and this is the funny Mind Of
The Atheist because the atheist doesn't
believe in a god allegedly but will tell
you that oh how can you believe in God
look at all the evil in the world and
that is nothing but a reflection of his
mindset because it shows you that he
didn't submit his will to God that's it
he's not in submission he's in a
rebellion everything he sees is a
problem for this person
a daily fight and that's why Buddha was
right life is suffering yes for them
definitely yeah most definitely you know
that that that's amazing that's
beautiful and um it really reminds me of
what Allah says in the Quran but before
I get to that I want to kind of you know
bring a little more context so you would
mentioned that you know you gave the
example of your son you know he wants
some chocolate you say you know it's not
good for you to take it your son is not
thinking logically and rationally this
chocolate is going to benefit me or
whatever you know using some kind of
principle to work off of
he just he's just going off his desires
you know this chocolate is pleasurable
you know so don't increase me and
dopamine it'll make me feel good give me
a little bit of a sugar rush or whatever
and you're looking at it as just someone
who knows better now Allah
he says there's two verses I want to
mention first he says he asks have you
seen the one who makes his own desires
as is God
and we don't just worship Allah by
praising him and praying to him we
worship Allah by obeying him so as soon
as you obey something over God then
you've made that thing you're a God you
know for example your own nuts your own
desires
if you you know turn and sway with every
sway of emotion that you have then
you've made that thing your God and when
you look at things like liberalism and
the way people are living in the west
that's exactly what they're doing even
with the argument you know look at all
this evil
they just these are just things they
don't like and Allah he says
something I think is beautiful because
it's straight to the point he says you
may love a thing which is bad for you
and you may hate a thing while it is
good for you you don't know and Allah
knows
man
beautiful
now a quick segue sorry Bob a quick
segue
something that a lot of people struggle
with nowadays especially young men
would be something I can't say on stream
but pornography addictions
now in order to break free from our
enough especially during this month of
Ramadan
we have built a full course called bya
break your addiction to help young men
with this and we all know the beautiful
Hadith of the process where he said to
young men if they can't get married to
fast to be able to control their sexual
desires
so this is the perfect month to do it so
click the link in the description sign
up for bya and break your addiction and
get closer to Allah
guaranteed or your money back you're
gonna quit pornography for good
inshallah
that is not that is not on the terms of
agreement it is yeah
bro I said
it's not it then full money like I mean
again the money the money is not the
goal it's just people have done the same
money is the tool in this world and
we're putting in our time then we're
getting other people to put in their
time so it's just a equal exchange
that's it yeah quit your addiction break
that for good inshallah
so now this being said Bubby I have a
very important question for you
you spoke a little bit with this briefly
and he touched it but
what are some big changes that you've
noticed even though it's day three of
Ramadan so far your first Ramadan as a
Muslim now alhamdulillah
um what are some things you've been
mindful of anything that you've been
noticing
for me it has been
the biggest change was in mental clarity
and a piece that I cannot describe but I
have to say here that I just took my
shahada
so obviously it goes hand in hand right
I feel like all my distractions are gone
and everything I do I can do in my time
frame
I don't have anything whatsoever that
distracts me on that note I want to say
I absolutely applaud you here on bring
out your course for breaking
pornography addiction
because this is the number one thing
that anybody in this modern day world
should do if he wants to progress in any
type of way
it's absolutely repulsive and I mean the
only thing you have to really think
about is you're looking at your phone or
at your computer and your playing with
yourself how pathetic is that it doesn't
befit any man well let's be completely
honest here so I stopped with that thank
God as well for our man years ago
it's just redundant ultimately
especially if you look into
a certain experiment of butterflies do
you know this butterfly experiment
no tell us
they did a butterfly experiment
ultimately where they found out that
butterflies are attracted to the most
colorful wings in the female so that
attracts them that arouses them that
gives them pleasure so they rebuilt
butterflies plastic butterflies with
absolutely insane patterns that you
don't find in nature even more colors
even brighter and what happened is the
butterflies the males they were more
attracted to those plastic butterflies
than they were in the real females they
didn't have to chase them they could
just go after those colorful butterflies
and they experience more pleasure with
that knowing that there is no
procreation happening they still went
after those plastic butterflies and in
the end the whole population died out
because those butterflies stopped having
intercourse with the female butterflies
realize that once I heard that man
it shifted everything in my mind because
I realized oh wow I was just attracted
to this plastic butterfly they're
bombarding me with imagery that is
triggering something in my brain that
makes me believe this is more beneficial
to me than the real thing because
ultimately sex is not that grandiose as
they sell it to you
if you look at YouTube videos for
example about food reviews
they are zooming in they're doing
close-ups of that burger and the cheese
is dripping and people are salivating
just watching this but what are you
really doing
you're just hijacking yourself again
salivating thinking about how amazing it
would be to bite into this burger
but you're just tricking your biological
Machinery which is designed to Simply
eat and this is what you learn during
Ramadan as well how much food do you
really need and then you're grateful
when you break your fast
so your body needs sustenance you just
need nourishment that's it but you can
hijack it and you can fantasize about
biting into that burger cool the same
thing can be done with another
biological urge which is of course
procreation God instilled that within us
it is pleasurable but it is here to make
children and once you become a dad you
realize that man you see that everything
you've been doing before that dating
going to restaurants holidays and
whatnot all of that was just about
making a kit
it's all just in place to make a kid
nothing else so the sooner you get to it
the better for you because you realize
that yeah sex is not about just endless
pleasure and Fantasies but it's about
making children and so this said you
have to understand that you've been
tricked your brain has been hijacked by
that imagery because it triggers your
sense of procreation you urge to
procreate but you're not doing it you're
shooting blanks now you're throwing it
to nothing so yeah sign up for that
course
it's definitely a fantastic benefit to
everybody that will subscribe to it I
believe inshallah inshallah and links in
the description guys let's put our
addictions
what was that yeah
The Butterfly Experience I've never oh
you never heard about it yeah yeah it's
crazy me neither no it's real yeah it's
real you can look it up I unfortunately
have no link now here but you can just
find it
so we got some questions from the
viewers right now from the audience so
first question is where can I find I
think even Bobby and share with man
podcast that you mentioned
don't be
it's not uploaded yet as far as I know
so sharehold man just traveled back to
Malaysia then he went to Mecca and then
he went back to the States so now he
finally arrived I believe so should be
up I don't know exactly where it has to
be edited I guess
in the next following days on one
message Foundation it should be not on
my channel maybe I'm gonna re-upload it
we'll see yeah inshallah next question
Islam alaikum what is the most amazing
thing you've learned from Islam thus far
congratulations on your reversion
brother alhamdulillah been watching you
just as long as I've been Muslim
the most amazing thing I learned is to
let go of everything additional in my
life
to keep it as simple as possible and you
cannot keep things simple if you are
rude belief is complicated this is a
quote again from Albert Einstein I
assume that again I cannot confirm and
he said if you cannot explain it to a
six-year-old
you don't understand it yourself
that's it so the Trinity cannot be
explained to a six-year-old it cannot be
explained to anybody basically and this
is why it is
seen as a mystery
and Islam what it did for me is to
clarify in my heart in my mind that God
is one and from there out on clarify
everything else in my life because now
everything else falls into place after I
submit it that is the most beautiful
thing about Islam the Simplicity and I
am a firm believer that the truth is
always simple so if you see for example
fitness programs or whatnot on YouTube
they tell you you have to do all kinds
of different exercises this and that
diet it's very very simple man calories
in calorie salt exercise
that's it you know so sure you can
refine certain things but if they try to
sell you something they make it
complicated so you feel that you are not
capable to understand it you don't get
it so I need somebody else to tell me
and that's the beauty of Islam everybody
can understand it of course if you want
to be intellectually stimulated you want
to research further you can find all of
that in Islam spiritually politically
even and whatnot but the root the
essence of Islam is simple and that
transforms your whole life and makes it
simple
next question for us are Vlad and you
again coming on stream today inshallah
they're going to come this coming week
so in a few days either Wednesday or
Thursday inshallah uh next question yeah
oh you know them
yeah I saw a bunch of videos and they
reacted to my shahada as well they're
nice guys
I got them and make it beneficial I mean
invite them to Islam I mean a guy in my
high school said that he wants to revert
After High School because his parents
are Catholic what advice should I give
him in a non-overwhelming way as we
shouldn't be delaying shahadas well
before anyone goes I just say he doesn't
have to tell anyone he could just be
Muslim just practice at home and I would
recommend getting it done because he
already sees that the truth but what do
you guys think
I mean the shahada is simple it's just
the acceptance of Islam you know who you
tell and what you do after that is is
who you tell what you do after that but
at the moment to accept Islam to
actually be a Muslim it's a belief and
then you testify to that belief so we
shouldn't over complicate being a Muslim
once you see that Islam is the truth
alhamdulillah
brother wahab the Warner says please
give Bobby my Salam my dear brothers I
miss you guys by the way
[Music]
we gotta all meet in person bro the
Warner us three you
um
as well
[Music]
are there any other topics that you
brother Rami or anho wanted to talk
about if not I want to ask if brother
Bobby has any questions for us
yeah I want to ask you about your wife
how's she dealing with the whole
reversion of you
oof
my wife is from Senegal she grew up in
Senegal but she's half Senegalese and
half French
so her father is Christian her mother
however as well her mother even grew up
in a monastery as far as I know with
nuns
and she belongs to the very very small
population of Christians in Senegal
which is by now I believe only 3.5
percent
for her she said it to me it was the
hardest thing when I opened up the Quran
two years ago because back then she
knows me
she knew this is it he's going to be a
Muslim because she knows that I cannot
stop my research on anything I have to
go all the way so when I open up the
Quran she already knew it and that's
when we had our biggest falling out
basically and I already started
argumenting for Islam I was like yeah
but here we went wrong as Christians you
know we made Jesus into our God etc etc
so that was the biggest issue for her
right then right there she already knew
it and then she kind of made peace with
it over the past two years
she was nagging me and told me yeah well
now he read the Quran you think you like
it but you didn't go to a mosque then I
went to the mosque and she was hoping
that I'm not going to like it but I
loved it so this was another
yeah part of it where she had to accept
it again so ultimately she came to peace
with it and we're in a very very happy
place right now
I'm not pushing anything on her that is
my path for now I have to walk it as a
man if God wills it then he will sit if
not then not we will see but as for
right now thank God we're in a very very
happy place as I said we're waiting for
another child now as well
inshallah everything is good man she had
to accept it by the way and today
actually we had a talk and she said you
know the thing that I respect about you
is that no matter what you did you
always went for the truth
um so therefore I have to respect that
as your wife no matter where it takes
you oh that is beautiful that's what
you're saying but but today you can
clearly say like okay if you understand
this if you're saying this that I only
go for the truth and you're seeing that
this is the truth then that means you
should accept it as well
but because I know her this would be not
the right thing to say because she
already knows she said it herself
so there's nothing I have to say
I guess lead by example from here or no
need by example bro and she sees it bro
but Allah says it's not the eyes that
are blind but it's the heart you know
and it's not we who who guides people
it's Allah so the biggest thing that
brother Bobby you could do is make him
do a
certainly
Insurance
absolutely phenomenal Transformations
here in Thailand a subscriber of mine he
went through a very very similar things
like myself the whole diet throughout
psychedelics route and whatnot he's from
America a blonde guy I had him on my
stream as well Daniel is his name if
you're watching he reverted as well
first he converted to Orthodox
Christianity and then when he started
watching my channel when I started doing
Islamic content he thought to himself
what is going on why would you even look
into this religion that doesn't make any
sense whatsoever but guess what he beat
me to it he even became a Muslim four
months ago
during that time he was in a Haram
relationship if you will with a Thai
woman
he just met her two months and he was so
in love with her he didn't know what to
do but once he reverted to Islam he
stopped the fornication and all of that
and he was just praying just praying
just praying for God to guide him for
Allah to guide him and what happened
then is one day she asks him are you
going to the mosque so yeah
can I come with so yeah okay they went
over there and on that given day there
was some sort of Sheikh from Arabia on
that little island of copangan
some Sheikh some scholar came down there
and he started talking to his girlfriend
two hours they were talking in Thai he
didn't understand much
and ultimately she accepted Islam right
then right there took the shahada
and the brothers said okay what's next
you want to do Nika so they got married
right then right there she fully
accepted Islam she's wearing the hijab
now they're married they're both Muslim
it's absolutely amazing I'm telling you
the story because he didn't know what to
do so he asked all the brothers and all
they could tell him is just make Dua
that's it just make Dua and in the end
it worked out amazingly
yes that's such a tricky situation man
yeah like I'm very happy I'm very happy
that they happen this way and you know
she ended up taking the shahada I was
like me personally if my woman was like
right there and she's talking to a man
for two hours like I wouldn't know
whether to like punch him in the neck or
like give him a big hug for like
actually you know opening your heart to
that yeah the thing is that he said this
shake there I think he's half Thai and
half Arab or something I'm not too sure
so he studied in Medina I believe so he
could convey it to her in her language
I believe I believe all of this all of
what you said is already my belief
system
so it was very important for her to have
that yeah the talk in her own native
language I guess
yeah yeah
that was a beautiful story honestly
again just it's very touching hand to
land the way that Allah guides some
people and the rate I wish you guides
them it's it's very beautiful
now uh we are gonna have to end soon so
Bobby the floor is yours if you have any
questions for us
brother this time I don't come prepared
with any type of questions so this if
anything is a celebration we're coming
back together we haven't seen each other
in a while I don't know exactly how long
it has been and now I'm the fourth
Muslim today alhamdulillah I'm happy
there's nothing to ask anymore brother
I can ask you about how your Ramadan is
going of course out of my own interest
s
and beautiful it's very beautiful
yes
no questions
I think alhamdulillah this is um
probably a beautiful note to end it on
um this has been such an amazing stream
it's been so again touching for me man
especially during the month of such a
beautiful reminder
um so let's make let's just take this
time to make Dua Allah
Allah
strengthen Bobby and uh increase him in
his Islam his Iman his knowledge and
make him a righteous leader for the
righteous Allah I mean may Allah forgive
us for our shortcomings and our slips
and our Falls and may Allah accept from
us our good deeds and amplify them for
us on the day of judgment
may Allah allow us to speak the truth to
implement the truth and to share it with
the rest of the world
and may Allah accept our fasting and
grant us a blessed Ramadan
do you guys have any final words before
we end off the Stream
Bobby it's been a pleasure we got to do
it again sometime
and let's meet in person if we can
inshallah
do you still run your studio
no Studio but we're in North America
near Toronto and on house in France
in France yeah yeah man what is going on
we're switching locations brother last
time I was in France you just came back
from Thailand you're in France
hey I don't know man I don't know
where you at um
uh right now I'm in Lily
I've been there if you want a really
good Islamic community go to the South
Marseille pretty much everybody yeah
yeah it's good over there good food
everything is hollow very nice well it's
very nice yeah
I must say I can recommend I was going
to say for you
um after Ramadan because I know it's not
possible right now but after Ramadan uh
maybe try just do me straight Carnival
like no fruits see if this helps a in
any way she performed autoimmune
disorder for sure brother that's what I
want to get back to as a dad you have
very little sleep and a lot of activity
that's when you start eating a bit more
you know but I have to get back on track
for sure
oh bro that's that's my bro right there
that you put up on the screen you know
really yeah yeah is this named salahin
yeah yeah
for supporting the channel goes a long
way male except from you and uh
I'm into it was I mean I mean I mean
just a quick reminder that when we're
fasting
um as Hadith mentions one of the best
times to make Dua for the fasting
believer is right before breaking the
fast
um and specifically in general just
during the fast but right before you're
about to break the fast inshallah so
take advantage of this time make a lot
of sincere Dua and inshallah we will get
what we want in this life and the next
all right and with that being said
Ramadan Mubarak everybody may Allah
bless you all and enjoy you have taught
inshallah when the time comes Allah
give us and this Earth what is good in
the afterlife what is good and protect
us from the punishment of the fire Allah
I mean inshallah we'll see you on the
next one